à partir du moment où on a conscience de
ce qu'est exactement l'histoire de
france on aime en schiste les
nostalgiques de la monarchie depuis
longtemps de nombreux reportages leur
sont consacrés à la télévision souvent
la date anniversaire de la décapitation
de louis saez le 21 janvier 1793 est un
bon prétexte pour leur donner la parole
moi qui suis un vieux royalistes depuis
cinquante ans un ancien camelots du roi
ça fait plaisir de voir les jeunes qu'il
continue la tradition chez les
nostalgiques de la fleur de lys
plusieurs courants s'opposent depuis des
siècles parmi eux celui d'action
française un mouvement royaliste
ultranationaliste aux idéaux d'extrême
droite dans d'autres à des chiens et
pour les charges et je peux plus a rendu
à la chambre en 13 ans 1988 ces
monarchistes vendéen est breton les
chouans ne partagez pas les mêmes idées
politiques mais avaient le même objectif
doter la france d'un roi avant l'an 2000
la france a besoin des rois besoin d'un
roi parce qu'un roi c'est une mystique
un roi cette une
c'est quelque chose qui comporte un peu
de merveilleux une idée partagée par un
autre royaliste convaincu stéphane bern
en 1985 à seulement 22 ans
ils défendent est déjà ses valeurs
royalistes avec beaucoup d'aplomb que ce
pas un peu ringard dans la france
d'aujourd'hui d'être aux royalistes
je crois que c'est une idée moderne et
qui commence à faire son chemin en
france parmi les royalistes il ya bien
évidemment les prétendants au trône de
france eux aussi passionne les
journalistes en septembre 1987 les
caméras couvrait l'intronisation de jean
d'orléans petit fils d'henri d'orléans
une cérémonie sur fond de querelle
familiale un absent en effet sur la
photo de famille henri le père de gens à
qui aurait dû revenir à couronne en
fichant ray n'ayant pas respecté les
règles j'ai reporté tout mon espérance
sur jean le comte de paris reproche à
son fils d'avoir divorcé et de s'être
remariée contre sa volonté dans les
années 90 la ferveur royalistes était
toujours palpable à la télévision
le jour du bicentenaire de la mort de
louis saez en 1993
certains nostalgiques et est toujours en
deuil notre jeunesse est perdu la france
est perdu il faut la sauver
il faut vider ce palais bourbon de tout
cela si c'est leur en 2007 pour rétablir
la monarchie
le leader du parti politique alliance
royale tentait de passer par les urnes
il proposait un retour à une monarchie
constitutionnelle
finalement il n'obtiendra pas ses 500
signatures aux élections suivantes non
plus d'ailleurs
pourtant en 2016 près d'un français sur
trois se disaient prêts à voter pour un
candidat royalistes
[Musique]